Just wondering if you could correct a rectile dysfunction?
I am unable to perform long enough during intercourse to finish.
Okay, so yes, a rectile dysfunction has to do with a
nitric oxide issue. Is it correctable?
Possibly I treated, I don't really treat that, but I do treat an ethereal dysfunction issue.
So, it's really on the same course of care.
So, endothelial dysfunction. So, your endothelium is the single layer
lighted of your blood vessels. They're epithelial cells. We call them endothelial cells in the bloodstree.
And underneath the endothelial cells, you have
blood vessels and you have smooth muscle tissue.
And both of them are sensitive to nitric oxide. It's called NOS,
endothelial nitric oxide synthase. You actually have receptors in the muscles
and receptors in the blood vessels as well. And you have to stimulate with that form of
nitric oxide, ENOS, to stimulate to contract which increases the blood flow.
So, it's going to contract the blood vessels. It's going to squish together the endothelial cells.
It's going to make a smaller lumen for the blood to flow, which increases blood flow.
The speed of blood flow. And from a blood pressure perspective, it's increasing blood pressure.
For someone who has increased high levels of blood pressure, so they go to the doctor,
they apply blood pressure, you want to use nitric oxide to relax those smooth muscles.
So, nitric oxide works to relax those muscles. Absence of nitric oxide increases that muscle
contraction and increases blood flow. So, with erectile dysfunction, you need nitric oxide
to help with the constriction of blood flow to that tissue. So, that's how you would treat that.
That's not our specialty, but that can be an issue with nitric oxide,
matter fact, the purple pill. That's exactly what it does. The danger of that is that it can
does infect your heart. So, the danger of using the purple pill for erectile dysfunction is that it
does affect your heart, and it is going to affect your blood pressure. So, you have to be very
careful with the use of nitric oxide. So, somebody who has a history of heart issues, history of
blood pressure issues, typically it's not recommended. You're the doctor still prescribed that.
It's really easy to get, but you've got to be really careful with that.
Nitric oxide has, you have to be careful with nitric oxide as well, if you have a history of cancer.
So, a history of cancer, you do not want to be using nitric oxide
supplementation. It's very common to use nitric oxide with bodybuilders as well.
It can help with work out fatigue. It can help with other work out issues with bodybuilding.
If you have a history of cancer, you don't want to do that. The reason is, is the nitric oxide.
The other thing that nitric oxide does, which is actually good for the heart, is it increases
what's called vascular endothelial growth factor. You may have heard of that as the
vending-ethvascular endothelial growth factor, which is good if you have heart issues. You want the
heart to be stimulated until ladle do vessels, but it's not good if you have cancer. So, especially if
you have a heart cancer, like a tumor type cancer, a vending-ethvascular endothelial growth factor
stimulation will lay down new vessels so it will actually be able to feed the cancer and give it
the ability to continue to grow. So, many drugs and nutritional therapies for cancer patients
are to block vedgef, so you would not use nitric oxide with anybody who has a history of cancer.
So, a lot of things that you would do for heart disease or maybe other comorbidities,
like discussed, you would not do for cancer. So, be aware of that too.